[Musique]
un abonnement en ligne c'est un peu
comme un mariage quand ça ne vaut plus
ce n'est pas toujours simple de s'en
libérer après la lune de miel certains
regrettent leur choix et souhaitent
rompre leur union avec des fournisseurs
de contenu des sites de rencontres des
services de bois de repas ou des
applications mobiles l'organisme option
consommateur à sonder les Canadiens à ce
sujet parmi les répondants qui ont déjà
été abonnés à des services avec paiement
mensuels automatiques 36% ont trouvé
difficile de briser leur engagement
option consommateur souligne que
certaines entreprises compliquent la
procédure en exigeant à leurs clients de
se désabonner via une plateforme
différente de celle de l'abonnement même
que selon ce sondage parmi ceux qui ont
déjà adhéré à ce type de contrat 24%
n'ont carrément pas réussi à s'en
défaire et ronge leurs freins dans un
mariage malheureux alors deux conseils
informez-vous des procédures de divorce
avant de dire oui je le veux et ajouter
une alerte à votre agenda pour éviter
que vos vœux ne se renouvellent
automatiquement passer le mot
[Musique]